reviews for the first two episodes of
Ahsoka are out and critics are making
their verdicts known about the latest
Star Wars series
as of the making of this video Ahsoka
has a critical approval rating in the
low 80s on review aggregator Rotten
Tomatoes Ed power of the Daily Telegraph
wrote in his four star review Ahsoka has
two qualities lacking from much recent
Star Wars output a solid story and an
imaginative visual Twist on George
Lucas's Universe Dan Jolin of Empire
magazine echoed the praise writing fans
of Clone Wars and Rebels will appreciate
this live-action continuation of Dave
filoni Saga while newcomers should dig
its promise of a different kind of force
Clash other critics were a bit more
reserved in their compliments Bob
Strauss of the San Francisco Chronicle
wrote Ahsoka has a fresh feel it would
be fresher though if Star Wars could
just find new themes to explore and do
so in ways that don't require so much
standing around talking